Now there are three distinct memory systems. Each involve different things to
remember. First, we learn to do things such as implicit procedures. This is the
procedural memory. The output for this type of memory mainly goes to the
Cerebellum and Striatum. When we experience emotional events. The output mainly
goes to the amygdala. When we consciously and explicitly remember a personal
event, or if we're trying to recall an answer, for say an essay exam. The
output goes to the hippocampus, which is just the first part of the process.
Then, these long-term memories get sent to various parts of the cortex for
long-term storage. So remember, elicit and procedural memory is involved in the
cerebellum and striatum. The Amygdala is involved in emotional memories, and
the Hippocampus is important for explicit and declarative type memories.